[Music]
okay
so last month one of you the viewer
emailed me saying oh i saw your video
where you're talking about how you've
never seen the huawei mate x like
outside of
a demo area but i have
i own one do you want me to like send
one to you maybe you can make a video
about it so first of all
very generous offer and we really
appreciated it but turns out it was
just a little bit risky with
international shipping and then
just with the state of the world right
now trying to insure it because it was
his personal phone and we definitely
wanted to get it back to him
but it wasn't fully guaranteed so
instead we just went down the rabbit
hole of
trying to buy one just seeing if i could
get my hands on one
here once and for all so as it turns out
you could probably guess
it's really hard to get one here in the
u.s they don't want it
they can't ship here but then uh dbrand
steps in
and they're like yeah we can we can
secure one and if i've learned
one thing over the years it's to never
doubt dbrand's ability to secure
really hard to get things this is the
same company that secured 12 ps5s
and 12 xbox series x's at the same time
in the height of their demand
still not sure how they pull that off so
yeah they got a mate x
so here we have it huawei mate xs
in collaboration with leica apparently
so the funny part about the timing of
just getting my hands on it now is
we have rumors saying the successor is
coming really soon
and i'll address that in a little bit
but i just wanted to get this phone for
myself and actually see what it's about
so right at the top is the phone with
the plastic
with a ton of warnings on it but that
comes right off and
this is the first time i'm holding the
phone and
wow it's a lot thinner than i expected
i'll get to that in a second
behind the phone is another card with a
printed set
of the same warnings the same
precautions
then underneath is the rest of the
hardware that actually comes with
this phone you get your paperwork and a
bumper case
that i'll show you you get a usbc to
usbc cable
then you also get your power adapter for
fast charging
and you get your usbc wired earbuds
okay so i wanted to get my hands on this
phone because like i said in my royal
flex
pi 2 video i've literally never seen
this phone before and now that i'm
holding it
and using it well there's a lot of
thoughts and observations that go
straight to the top
so when it's closed it looks like a
normal phone
just a big phone 6.6 inch diagonal phone
but you know you can see the fingerprint
reader doubles
as a power button on the right hand side
you've got your volume rocker
the screen goes pretty close to the
edges but then of course
there's a couple obvious quirks so you
can see the fold of course
and you can also see the usb-c port is
all the way over to the right-hand side
and two it's very smooth feeling because
of course the display is what's wrapping
around on the sides
and they've polished and smoothed the
right side
to sort of look just like the screen
wrapping around the left side
but when you look at it you can kind of
tell the bezel on the right is just a
little
thicker than their cutoff of the display
on the left
kind of reminds me of the first ever
galaxy note edge so you can use it
closed just like a normal phone but
that's not why you get this phone
right you got to be opening it up all
the time to get your money's worth
so to open this phone up you flip it
over and there's a red button
and you press that button and the back
part of the display is spring loaded and
it flips out
halfway open and then it's up to you to
push it all the rest of the way open
and sort of snaps into place when it's
flat and then you've got your full size
eight inch 2480 by 2200 oled
canvas for all the productivity and big
screen tasks in the world
okay so a couple of thoughts so first of
all i was immediately
pretty struck by how thin this is it's
5.5 millimeters thick at the thin part
and that of course means when you fold
it over that's 11 millimeters that's
not much thicker than a normal
smartphone these days but the reason
this whole thing is able to be
so thin is mainly because these wings of
the phone as i'll call them
are basically just screen and battery so
the total combined battery is 4 500
milliamp hours
with some battery in each side but
pretty much all the rest of the
components of this phone are
packed into this column over here that
low key kind of acts as a grip when you
start to get used to holding it
but that's why the usbc port is over
here that's where the kirin 990
processor
and eight gigs of ram and half a
terabyte of storage
are and that's of course where all the
cameras are there's no camera cutouts
for a selfie camera or anything like
that
all of the cameras live over here in
this column and there's four of them
there's a 40 megapixel primary camera an
ultra wide
a 3x telephoto zoom and a depth sensor
and this is a review of these of course
this is just my impressions but i do
like the idea that in a folding phone
you can take advantage of the main
cameras for everything including selfie
stuff
so with the mate xs you hit the button
to switch to a selfie
and then you literally flip the phone
around and you're using those huge
high quality main cameras to take
selfies so you can use the ultrawide
or even the zoom if you're into that and
then also because this is screen
on the back it's off most of the time
but if you want to hit this button
and turn the back screen on now you can
show people
as you're taking a photo of them what
that photo's going to look like so
yeah there you are so now with the
viewfinder mirrored on the back
you can imagine being able to hand the
phone to someone and like direct them
exactly how to take the photo based on
what you see so i feel like we all kind
of know
huawei's software experience here in the
us is a bit nuked because
they don't have a relationship with the
us anymore and so even if you are able
to get the phone here
there's no google play services it's not
ideal but there are some pretty nice
software features in here where you get
control over app scaling
so some apps get column support on the
big screen so
there's a lot of good stuff but and this
is the other side of the coin
there's downsides too and you'll
probably saw these coming so the crease
there's no getting around it there's
still a crease on folding phones and it
can kind of catch your eye sometimes but
i feel like this is as good as it gets
with the current tech when you're
actually looking at the contents of
what's on the screen you really don't
notice the crease it's just when
you run your fingers straight over it or
it catches a light a certain way
then you do notice it but speaking of
catching the light a certain way
the built-in screen protector that's on
this phone which is super important for
protecting the super soft flexible oled
doesn't uniformly go up to the edges so
there's notches and cutouts everywhere
and it caught my eye all the time so i'm
not going to pull it off because
i know better i know better than that
but the dust collecting
on these uneven edges and just the way
the light hits it you can't tell me that
wouldn't eventually bother you a little
bit but hey better to have a screen
protector than not
because unfortunately i've placed this
phone down like a
normal phone a few too many times and
i've ended up with some
scratches on the back plastic because
well when you put it down it literally
touches the ground so if you put it on a
desk
that plastic is touching a desk if
there's any sort of grit or any
particles or materials at all on that
surface that's going up straight against
the plastic and most phones are cool
with that of course but
this plastic screen protector is like
scratches at a level one with
deeper grooves at a level breathing too
hard so i'm not shocked that it's
already starting to see some marks
but of course the whole point is you get
the marks in the screen protector
and you're not damaging the screen
basically the bumper case
that comes with this phone is like the
best possible solution because then it
sort of raises it up
off of whatever surface you put it down
on so if you're
super never want to get any sort of
scratches on it put the bumper case on
it's a little less elegant but then you
don't get scratches and then the hinge
here on the xs
is slightly improved from the x so you
can see there's these dust caps now and
the metal back to the hinge to keep it
almost completely gapless when it's
folding but of course it's still not
going to be water or dust resistant or
anything
they're just doing the best they can so
at the end of the day on one hand
this feels like the most
advanced sexiest folding phone
i've ever seen it's it's pretty stunning
hardware but on the other hand
like i was saying in the flexpi video
i'll link it below it's just
it's just not quite technically ready to
be doing this
outside fold thing so i'm really curious
about the next version because like i
said word on the street is
the huawei mate x2 or whatever this next
version is called is
supposedly coming out within the next
month or so and headlines suggest it's
going to be switching to the inside
folding design
like the galaxy fold which would make a
lot of sense given the current state of
the tech you know there's a couple other
things i'd like to see i'd like to see a
120 hertz display
i like to see ho maybe a slightly bigger
battery i know they want to keep it all
thin and sexy like this but yeah i'm
very curious now
about how folding stuff goes forward
seeing how this ended up you know do we
go straight to
folding on the inside and then come back
to the outside fold when the folding
screen
tech is better we'll see let me know
what your thoughts are below if you
think we should still do the outside
fold stuff
or not that's pretty much it i'm glad i
finally got my hands on the stone
and uh now i know that's been it
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one peace